body collectors carry a victim of kovat
19 than the dusty hills of this
working-class neighborhood and the
outskirts of Lima it's dangerous work
few Peruvians are willing to do as the
corona virus spreads with alarming speed
through the country many of those who do
dare to take the job or poor Venezuelan
migrants now thrust to the frontline of
the pandemic I'm always afraid afraid to
infect my family when I go home my
children but it's something I have to
face to continue working and to be able
to put food on the table on March 16th
Peru became one of the first countries
in Latin America to impose a strict
lockdown but now more than two months
later it's one of the region's worst
affected by coronavirus with more than a
hundred thousand cases experts say
people's behavior is to blame in a
country where more than 70% of the
population lives hand-to-mouth President
Martin Baqarah says the government has
done everything it can to flatten the
curve of contagion see him we have
always acted looking at what was best
for the people and we will continue
doing so even more considering how
delicate a context we are now and with
the number of confirmed cases having
doubled in just two weeks
hospitals are under increasing strain
from the capital Lima all the way to the
Amazon leading to shortages of medicine
emergency oxygen supplies in critical
care beds medical staff at this hospital
in Lima protested the lack of protective
equipment they say substandard hospital
conditions have laid bare that gaping
holes in Peru's underfunded health care
system it's like a horror movie inside
it looks like a graveyard of dead bodies
patients die in their chairs in
wheelchairs or regular chairs and in the
last few days basic medicines have
become scarce across the country without
Toyota's shutting down some pharmacies
accused of raising prices its crisis
upon a crisis in a country that taught
her that moved in time to stop the virus
only to find itself hit with deadly
force Alice
rampe et al Jazeera